jean sans peur avait l'ambition de
reconstituer l'ancienne lotharingie il
fit don assassiné louis d'orléans et
rentra dans paris en armes
mais lui aussi fut assassiné et la
guerre civile plongeant le pays dans le
chaos
le nouveau roi d'angleterre henri st
voulu alors donné le coup de grâce à la
france
il l'a envahi
bhatti le dauphin charles secte qui
s'étaient échappés de paris et signa
avec les bourguignons un traité dans
lequel son fils henry 6 était déclarée
unique héritier à la couronne de france
tout était perdu
la france devenait anglaise
mais jeanne d'arc
dans une ardeur patriotique suivi par le
peuple l'ibère orléans des anglais et
persuade le dauphin charles vii de se
faire sacrer lui aussi roi de france à
reims
charles 7 reprend à leur courage ils
signent une paix avec le nouveau duc de
bourgogne philippe lebon il regagne
militairement la normandie et avec la
capitulation de bordeaux ils chassent
définitivement les anglais de la france
mettant fin à la guerre de cent ans
mais les conflits avec la bourgogne
perdure
en france à charles vii succèdent louis
et en bourgogne à philippe le bon succès
de charles le téméraire ce qui relance
les combats charles le téméraire un lion
prend la principauté de liège s'allie au
luxembourg achète une part de l'alsace à
l'autriche est envahi la lorraine mais
il est hué par les lorrains louis aux
annexes alors la bourgogne et la
provence rétablissant l'ordre à partir
de tout
à l'est de l'europe entre temps le
peuple des turcs avaient embrassé
l'islam devenu musulman il avait effacé
l' empire byzantin et envahit la
bulgarie et la roumanie
en espagne par contre les musulmans sont
définitivement chassés par les rois qui
unifiant leur royaume avait achevé la
reconquista
en france sous le règne de charles vite
la situation est redevenue paisible la
bretagne s'est jointe au royaume
les principautés sont obéissantes les
impôts sont diminués la justice
s'améliore les commerces les richesses
et la population augmente et sous
l'influencé des artistes italiens la
renaissance française commence
pour s'assurer la paix charles wuyts
signe des traités avec henri 7
d'angleterre avec l'empereur maximilien
premier d'autriche et avec ferdinand ii
d'aragon qui avait commencé les grandes
navigations de découverte avec
christophe colomb mais quand charles ou
8 envahi l'italie en réclamant son
héritage
le royaume de naples il est battu par
les armées de venise et de la sainte
ligue du paf jules 2 les suisses entre
temps avait envahi la lombardie et
l'empiré d'autriche avait annexé la
lorraine
à la mort du pape jules ii la sainte
ligue s'affaiblit françois 1er devenu
roi de france
put alors battre les suisses et se
partager le nord de l'italie avec venise
dans l'empiré d'autriche la réforme à
nîmes les esprits martin luther met en
question l'église et protestent contre
l'avidité des pâtes mais il est aussitôt
mise au ban par le très catholique
charles quint d'apps bourg charles quint
héritier de l'empiré d'autriche et
d'espagne réprima durement
l'indépendance des riches provinces du
nord et assimile à même des territoires
français françois 1er
répondit alors en envahissant le royaume
de naples
mais il fut fait prisonnier il se libéra
et tenta une deuxième invasion de
l'italie sans y parvenir il repoussa
alors une tentative d'invasion de la
france par charles quint
qui entre temps s'étaient partagé la
hongrie avec les turcs
en pologne le royaume s'étendait en
héritant de la lituanie et de la bohème
en angleterre le roi henry vite se
proclamer chef suprême de l'église
anglicane se détachant de l'église de
rome en france le roi henry 2 gagne une
part de la lorraine mais en italie il
est battu par charles quint l'empereur
des territoires sur lesquels le soleil
ne se couche jamais
pourtant charles quint abdique et son
énorme empire est divisé en deux
son frère ferdinand premier hérite de la
couronne impériale d'autriche son fils
philippe 2 hérite de l'espagne des pays
bas et de la franche-comté ferdinand
premier annexes
aussitôt la bohème
en france la sévère réforme protestante
de jean calvin avançait à paris la nuit
la saint-barthélemy n'a dû réaction des
catholiques avaient provoqué le massacre
de 3000 protestants huguenots c'était la
guerre civile
en espagne philippe 2 s'empare du
portugal et de ses colonies
mais quand il envoie son invincible
armada pour envahir l'angleterre
il subit une désastreuse défaite les
pays-bas en profite alors pour se
libérer de la domination espagnole
il signifie en république des provinces
unies et commencent leur expansion
coloniale
en france henri iii avait désigné un
héritier protestants son cousin henri de
bourbon qui prit le nom d'henri iv et
paris catholique depuis toujours ne
voulait pas de roi protestant
alors henri iv s'exclama paris vaut bien
une messe abjura la confession
protestante et avec l'édit de nantes
donne à la liberté de culte à tous les
citoyens la france pacifié henri iv
comment ça les grandes navigations
française
l'amérique les inde madagascar et le
moyen-orient sont explorées
son fils louis xiii colonisent la
guadeloupe
et la martinique et sur les conseils de
son ministre le cardinal de richelieu
il poursuit les combats contre
l'angleterre l'espagne et l'autriche
mais quand à richelieu succède le
cardinal mazarin
malgré les oppositions du parlement et
des nobles la monarchie absolue avec
louis xiv le roi soleil est instauré la
france devient alors la première
puissance militaire et culturelle
d'europe
la politique économique de colbert
renforce les finances vauban fortifie
les frontières
l'alsace et la franche-comté sont
annexés haïti est pris aux anglais et
des colonies se forme dans louisiane où
la nouvelle orléans est fondée
mais les frais des colonies et des
guerres ajoutée aux fastes de la cour et
à la construction de versailles
dépouillent les finances de l'état le
peuple affamé proteste louis xiv le
réprime alors sans pitié il ne comporte
plus les états généraux révoque la
liberté de culte et pour affirmer sa
supériorité militaire
il déclare la guerre à l'angleterre il
se retrouve face à une coalition
réunissant l'angleterre les provinces
uni l'espagne la suède la savoie et l'
empire d'autriche qui avait enlevé la
hongrie au tueur
à cette époque le portugal avait repris
son indépendance à l'espagne
l'angleterre
doté d'une puissante marine qui dominait
lé maire était devenu le royaume uni
fusionnant les cosses sous and start
avant qu'une révolution pacifique
la glorieuse révolution anglaise ne
renversent l'histoire le parlement
anglais institut alors une monarchie
constitutionnelle
mettant fin au pouvoir des souverains
les reléguant au seul cérémonie
officielle en france le pouvoir du roi
louis 15 reste entier la paix et la
prospérité reviennent et la lorraine et
pacifiquement intégrer mais quand louis
15 h est la corse à gênes ils
rencontrent l'opposition du général
pascal paoli paoli avait établi une
constitution qui donnait le droit aux
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes
néanmoins il fut soumis par louis 15 qui
assimile à la corse à la france et comme
le royaume uni avait gagné des
territoires français aux inde et en
amérique du nord
le nouveau roi de france louis saez et
d'un les insurgés américains dans leur
guerre d'indépendance contre les anglais
dans l'est de l'europe les puissances
naissante de prusse et de russie
s'étaient partagé la pologne avec
l'empiré d'autriche qui avait même
intégré le luxembourg et les pays bas
en france les idées de la révolution
anglaise avait animé un mouvement
intellectuel et scientifique
les lumières la providence de dieu était
remise en question à la lumière de
l'esprit critique et le rôle du roi et
de l'état étaient contestées montesquieu
diderot voltaire rousseau et d'autres
hommes de culture demander des réformes
louis saez était un souverain modéré il
permit l'opposition restera la tolérance
envers les protestants et randy les
infos plus égalitaire devant le refus
des nobles et de l'église de payer une
taxe sur leur possession il ira jusqu à
restaurer les états généraux mais le
tiers état composé par les représentants
du peuple
n'acceptez plus est ancien ordres
privilégiés se retirant des états
généraux le peuple français exigeait une
nouvelle constitution
avec les réformes encore plus radicale
que celle du roi les privilégiés sous
couvert encore et le 14 juillet 1789
saône à leurs fins
le gouverneur de paris et pelé le peuple
en la bascule
le roi 8 16 et sa famille sont arrêtés
c'est la révolution française les droits
de l'homme et du citoyen sont déclarés
provoquant la fuite précipitée de tous
les privilégiés et même de louis saez
mais il est capturé et guillotiné ainsi
que la reine marie antoinette
la monarchie est alors abolie et la
première république française est
déclarée cependant malgré la déclaration
des droits de l'homme
les jacobins de robespierre instaure le
régime de la terreur 18000 personnes
opposées à la révolution seront
guillotinés indignés l'empereur
d'autriche léopold ii 2 et le roi de
plus guillaume deux déclare alors la
guerre à la république française de plus
à paris la situation s'aggrave la
brutalité de la terreur avait provoqué
des vengeances robespierre lui même
avait été guillotinés